what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
wow what a finale for wanda vision
there's a lot that we thought would
happen that did happen and a lot that we
hoped and thought would happen that
didn't happen
either way it was truly fantastic and
there is a ton to break down so let's
get started and dive
right into it but first if you're new
and you love marvel be sure to subscribe
hit the notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the future marvel
videos including ones for the falcon and
the winter soldier coming
up so i'll first start off by explaining
the two end
credit scenes then i'll tell you what
one division and the post-credit scenes
set up for the future of the marvel
cinematic universe including my
breakdown and theory of who the villain
of doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness is going to be then we'll do
a scene by scene
shot by shot breakdown of the entire
episode of the wanda vision finale
so starting with the first in credit
scene it starts with jimmy wu telling
everybody to gather around he's naming
locations that would be good spot for
people to set up shop like
medicals going in the pharmacy and
they're going to start gathering
evidence
he meets up with monica rambo and he
asks where darcy is
and monica explains that darcy said that
debriefs are for the weak basically
she's not attending
she literally came in for one scene to
hit hayward
and trap him so they could catch him
then she dipped kind of like white
vision which of course we'll talk about
later
hayward is taken into custody because he
commanded a lot of crimes trying to
frame wanda
and kill her then of course he stole
vision's body and turned him into a
weapon which is against the sokovia
accords and the vision's own
will not to mention he tried to shoot
some kids whether or not they were real
or not it doesn't really matter he shot
at some kids but then an unnamed agent
goes up to monica and says they're
asking for you in the theater
monica goes into the theater and the
agent follows her only to reveal that
she is
actually a scroll and is actually the
one that needed to talk to her
now scroll are no surprise to monica
rambo she of course was the little girl
the daughter of maria rambo in captain
marvel it doesn't specifically say who
this particular scroll is but she does
say
that she was sent by an old friend of
monica's mothers
he heard you've been grounded he'd like
to meet with you
monica asks where and the woman points
up now since they are saying he
and they're saying he is an old friend
of monica's mother maria
she is most likely referring to one of
two people one would be talos from
captain marvel
leader of the scroll that we know so far
who also made an appearance in the
post-credits scene of spider-man far
from home but who she's most likely
referring to
is actually nick fury nick fury of
course worked with captain marvel and
maria rambo in captain marvel and we do
know that he
is up he is in space in what we believe
to be the peak
swords headquarters in the comics that
is located above earth
this is why she is pointing up because
right now nick fury is
up in space this is definitely setting
up monica rambo to play a key part in
disney's and marvel's upcoming
secret invasion disney plush show this
will involve the scroll
nick fury and it looks like it's now
going to involve monica rambo
we then have the second mind-blowing and
credit scene with wanda
all by herself this scene was shot in
new zealand although it's unclear if
that's where they want us to believe she
is right now
wanda is alone in the mountains all by
herself drinking some tea
and she goes inside the kitchen to get
some more tea but the camera continues
past the kitchen into the bedroom this
is where we see
the scarlet witch hovering over the bed
in true doctor strange fashion
studying the darkhold or the book of the
damned as agatha calls it
as she is studying it it looks like she
is casting spells and we can see
a bunch of different circles surrounding
her and if you take a look in the book
when agatha is reading out of it to
wanda we can actually see on the left
page here
a bunch of different circles in here as
well and i believe these are actually
different dimensions
universes realms whatever marvel is
going to title them
now some people are wondering if there
are two different wandas now one the
scarlet witch and one wanda since we see
two of them in this scene but it looks
like wanda is simply astral projecting
like doctor strange did in his movie
if you recall when doctor strange was
sleeping he was also
studying at the same time this is
essentially what wanda is doing
however as agatha said she is stronger
than the sorcerer supreme so she can
actually be
up and moving and drinking tea and still
studying at the same time
seems to be a little bit more than
strange could do but again this leads
into doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
but as she is studying she hears the
voice of her children
and she hears them say mom help help
mom please not only does this tell us
that her kids are actually alive
somewhere but it tells us that they're
in distress
and it seems like at the very end wanda
knows where they are
so what is most likely happening here
and this gets a little bit into my
theory now
is that wanda with those circles around
her was actually looking through
different realms to find her kids
she felt them and knew that they still
existed somewhere just not in this
earthly realm so she was searching
other realms until she eventually found
them but when she finds them they're in
distress
and they need help and i believe that
they could be in the hell dimension
now i know we didn't see mephisto at any
point in time but it does make sense
that tommy and billy would be stuck in
the hell dimension
in the comics wanda's twin boys are
actually shards of the soul of the demon
mephisto
she has the twin boys but eventually
mephisto would take them back
and they would cease to exist something
similar could be happening here whereas
tommy and billy don't necessarily exist
in the earthly realm but they have moved
on
to mephisto's hell realm because they
are actually part his kids
we knew that billy and tommy weren't
visions kids because he's a synthezoid
he can't have kids but
wanda had to get impregnated somehow so
perhaps they really were
part of the soul of mephisto and they
have now returned to the hell dimension
where he resides
after all agatha did call the darkhold
the book of the damned and
where did the damned go they go to hell
now akatha did confirm that this book
that we saw
was indeed the darkhold not that we
really had any doubt
this means that the evil elder god
shathun or
mephisto somebody like that is coming
there's an evil
big bad villain on his way and i'll tell
you exactly how this all works
agatha tells wanda give me your powers
and i'll let you keep your family and
this town and your fake reality
agatha specifically says surrender your
powers
making it very clear that wanda wasn't
actually born with these powers but they
were actually given to her and since
they were given to her
she can give them up ultimately in this
episode wanda goes on to become the
scarlet witch and agatha says
you don't know what you've done and then
she says you have
no idea what you've unleashed and what
she's referring to
is chaos magic this is because her chaos
magic comes from the one who created
the darkhold you see the book the
darkhold was created by the evil elder
god c'thun
he was the original creator of chaos
magic
and he put a part of this inside of the
darkhold and in the comics he put a part
of his chaos magic inside of
wanda and he did that so he could
eventually return to the earth
realm so essentially what wanda has done
here is
enable a way for him to return to the
earth realm
after all agatha does say that there's a
whole section in the dark hole dedicated
to the scarlet witch
most likely because this is how he's
going to return
now again agatha calls the book the book
of the damned so i again will say that
chathun or the main villain that's
coming could be a cross between
c'thun and mephisto because where do the
damned go
they go to hell where mephisto controls
that realm it's clear they're alive and
it's clear that they're trapped in a
different realm and this
is where doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is going to come
into play
wanda is going to start tearing apart
different universes and dimensions in
search for her children
and doctor strange's job is protecting
the main reality so naturally he's going
to come into play
and he will no doubt realize what wanda
has done
opened a portal for a way for mephisto
or c'thun or combination of the two
to get back to earth and this is
obviously doctor strange's problem to
deal with unfortunately
after all we know that doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is
supposed to be marvel's
first horror type movie scott derrickson
was originally directing it and now sam
raimi is directing it both
horror film directors so we're
definitely going to be getting some
super evil being coming in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
this is who i believe is going to be a
combination of c'thun and mephisto
and that is my theory on what is said at
the end let's now go into our shot by
shot breakdown
now the last few episodes of one
division marvel hasn't exactly been
dropping a ton of easter eggs but of
course there are still some and there is
a ton to break down
we start with the very first scene we
start off right where we left off with
one division episode eight
agatha has wanda's twin boys hostage
wanda tells agatha that her powers work
outside and agatha says that she's
counting on it this is because agatha
wants to take this power this chaos
magic from
wanda and wanda can see that as she uses
the magic against her agatha does
kind of start to take it away from her
and it starts to drain wanda
things get intense when wanda drops a
car on agatha and then we get a wizard
of oz easter egg here
wanda goes up to the car and she only
sees her boots under the car
this is a direct reference to dorothy's
house falling on the wicked witch of the
east and only her boots remain in the
wizard of oz
then white vision comes into the picture
and wanda thinks it might be the real
vision but she learns very soon
that it is not and he is there to kill
her but of course her vision comes to
save the day
now if you look closely you can see that
vision has an arc reactor in his head
where the mind stone would originally be
this looks just like the arc reactor
that tony stark had in his chest that
powered his iron man suits
could this be the same technology that
tony stark used could he have given
sword permission to use this technology
or did they use it without his consent
this could set up
armor wars armor wars is a series coming
to disney plus that is going to focus on
war machine and iron man armor
specifically what happens when tony
stark's technology falls into the wrong
hands and if sword specifically hayward
who we know is bad is using tony stark's
technology
this could definitely set up armor wars
and white vision to return
for armor wars now when vision saves
wanda he says
i know why you made this world and wanda
says i can fix it
but then vision says can you he knows
without the hex that he'll go away and
he knows that wanda is going to have to
make that choice so what he's really
asking is
can you let go of me and the kids agatha
cracks a joke about her ex and her
boyfriend in the same room who will she
choose and
we finally get the scene where wanda
says this is our home and vision says
then let's fight for it we then have the
epic scene where we get vision vs vision
and the scarlet witch
versus this insanely knowledgeable and
ancient witch agatha harkness
we then go to monica and who we believe
to be quicksilver
however we soon discover that this
really isn't the case as sad as it is we
learned that quicksilver
is actually ralph specifically ralph
boner
weird choice there marvel but this is
the ralph that agatha has been teasing
this whole entire series
and he actually does tell monica at one
point this is my man cave a place to
chillax while the missus
is stirring up trouble now since he's
under her control he truly does believe
that agatha is indeed his wife but the
big question here is does he actually
have powers is he actually somebody of
importance
i believe that ralph could be the person
that is in witness protection that jimmy
wu was talking about all along
after all ralph boner is a very weird
name one that he himself even laughs at
so it could be made up
hopefully it is and hopefully he has a
bigger role to play in the marvel
cinematic universe but
that may not be the case when monica
realizes that it's his necklace that
agatha is using to control him
and she rips it off and he comes back he
says please spare my life like he has no
powers at all
like he can't do anything if so and if
this is the case
weird move by marvel to bring evan
peters in as a fake
quicksilver perhaps them doing this is
them truly telling us that the fox x-men
are dead and aren't coming to the mcu
we go back to vision versus vision and
white vision says that
wanda must be neutralized and then he
does something rather
interesting he says so much to you and
he goes for vision's mind stone in his
head
this is most likely because he thinks
that the mind stone is real and is
powering this vision
but we learn at the end of this episode
that vision is created from the part of
the mind stone that lives in wanda the
energy it gave her but we know it's not
the actual mind stone and
can't survive out of the hex and it dies
with vision but the white vision doesn't
seemingly know that
and thinks it's real most likely because
sword thought that it was real
we then go to sword who of course is
trying to control white vision but they
say that vision systems are overloaded
and they can't get anything through
this implies the new vision is already
starting to think for himself
something that definitely happens just a
few scenes later and of course hayward
truly is
a villain in his own sense and truly a
jerk
he says he's going to lie because no one
knows that there are two visions since
wanda isn't broadcasting anymore and he
says that no one will care anyways once
he kills wanda who he deems as the
threat and will make out to be a villain
but our hero jimmy wu sneakily steals a
phone
and teases hayward that the fbi will be
there in an hour and then escapes from
the cups and calls his team now jimmy
speaks to somebody named
cliff and cliff could be perhaps one of
two people there is a cliff garner in
marvel comics who was formerly of the
air force and investigated the possible
conspiracy of
control he wasn't really a big character
in any way shape or form
a very minor character but it could also
be cliff randall who was a member of the
alien race known as the collective
intelligence
he was a sleeper agent living on earth
as a normal human being until being
recalled by
the intelligence when the collective
intelligence left earth he sabotaged
their ship
destroying it thereby saving earth they
could very well change this to be a
scroll storyline cliff could actually be
a scroll
and since one of the fbi agents was a
scroll this could very well line up we
then go back to wanda and agatha and
agatha name drops the darkhold and as i
mentioned in my theory she mentions
there's a
whole chapter about the scarlet witch in
the darkhold most likely due to her
chaos magic and c'thun
but then agatha says something very very
interesting she says that wanda's power
exceeds that of the sorcerer's supreme
meaning that wanda's chaos magic is
stronger than dr strange's magic
now in avengers in-game the ancient one
told the hulk that doctor strange
is supposed to be the best of them but
keep in mind that wanda isn't a master
of the mystic arts so she doesn't really
count here this doesn't mean that doctor
strange is supposed to be stronger than
wanda
plus she didn't say that he was the
strongest she said that he was supposed
to be the best and there's a lot more to
being the best
than just strength as i mentioned before
agatha is holding the book where it
shows the scarlet witch and we see
the circles on the left side which are
most likely realms or dimensions
whatever they're going to call them
for example mephisto is in the hell
dimension nightmare is in the dream
dimension
in thor they also mentioned that there
are nine realms but i believe these are
different and are really referring to
different worlds and planets
wanda says that she is not evil and
agatha then releases everyone
and dottie answers vision's question
that he had once upon a time where he
asked where are all of the children
and as it turns out wanda kept all the
kids trapped in their rooms
and daddy is asking if she could let
them out specifically let her daughter
out
agatha releases all of the town's people
from wanda's hex and all the townspeople
know that it's wanda that is doing this
to them
at the same time the twins using billy's
psychic powers realize what's happening
and go to find their mother they reveal
that the town's people all
feel wanda's pain when they sleep they
have wanda's nightmares again pointing
to my theory that mephisto and c'thun
and maybe nightmare will all be merged
into one villain and that they're
somehow influencing things with wanda
they all attack wanda and it becomes too
much for wanda she has a little bit of a
meltdown and starts to choke all of them
with her magic agatha tells her to
release them and she does
releasing the hex for a brief moment
sword takes this opportunity to move
into the hex
and as we learn wanda tied her family to
the reality
billy and tommy and vision kind of start
to decimate
like people did with thanos snap they're
kind of being dusted away as the hex
goes away
so in order for wanda to save them she
puts back up the hex
the family then unites to fight and they
look just like the incredibles which was
on the theater display a few episodes
ago then they take off
vision vs vision wanda vs agatha and the
boys get to take out the military which
they do rather easily now we find out
that the white vision is tasked with
taking out
vision but vision kind of pulls a
reverse psychology on him he says that
he's not the true vision
only a conditional one and this
intrigues white vision
he says he requests elaboration then
comes a truly
awesome scene that some people might
have a hard time following
our vision says you are familiar with a
thought experiment the ship of theseus
in the field of identity metaphysics the
white vision then explains that the ship
of theseus is an artifact in a museum
over time its planks of wood rot and are
replaced with
new planks so the question is when all
of these planks are gone when no
original planks remain and they've
replaced them all with new ones
is it still truly the ship of theseus
since none of it is from the true ship
of theseus
and that's just one part the second part
is if you take those wood planks that
are rotting
restore them take the rot off of them
and put them back on the boat
is that the ship of theseus considering
the fact that it's the original wood
minus the rot but the answer to this is
neither one
of them by themselves is the true ship
but in fact
both of them are the true ship and of
course they're comparing the two
different versions of the ship
the one that is replaced with new wood
entirely and the one that has its wood
restored
to both visions both of these visions
are not the original vision
yet they both are part of the original
vision and together
combined they make the real vision the
white vision has all of the vibranium
but does not have the mind stone whereas
the other one has everything the mind
stone gave him
and the memories of the original vision
however
vision awakens the mind of the white
vision and he discovers that sword was
actually kind of mind controlling him
they were doing this with the reactor
inside of his head
controlling him as a weapon but vision
frees his mind
he frees him of swords control and we
can see that he becomes free as
his eyes become more human and now you
have the vision with the original parts
the vibranium and the memories of the
original vision as well
therefore making him the real vision
however
he then bails he has a sudden
self-realization that he
is vision and he bounces and we don't
know where he went but one thing is for
sure he will definitely
be returning at some point in time in
the marvel cinematic universe
hopefully i explained that in a way that
makes sense i did my best
meanwhile monica rambo is saving the
twins from
hayward her new powers given to her from
the hex allow her to absorb the bullets
and come out unharmed meanwhile billy
and tommy have powers of their own
all way too powerful for hayward and he
bails too but he bails because he's a
little wimp although he doesn't get far
because darcy shows up to save the day
and then she bails we don't see her for
the rest of the show
a lot of bailing in this episode we then
go to wanda using the same
mind tricks that she used on the
avengers and age of ultron and she uses
them on agatha to take her back
to where she originally killed her
mother and her witch coven
wanda dives into her memories and then
manipulates them
all of the witches come back to life and
go at agatha
until agatha turns it around all of the
witches realize who wanda
is she's a witch the scarlet witch and
here's where we get
even more evidence that a really big bad
villain such as c'thun
is coming the witches say that wanda is
the one that has been written about
referring to the section about her in
the darkhold which was written by c'thun
then they say she's a harbinger of chaos
now the exact definition of a harbinger
is a person or thing that announces or
signals the approach
of another so wanda is signaling the
approach of
chaos or the person who created chaos
magic
c'thun who again i believe is going to
be a big bad of the mcu and a villain in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
now agatha states that power isn't
wanda's problem it's knowledge
and as she says this a magical crown of
wandas appears on her head the scarlet
witch crown
agatha knows this is chaos magic and
asks once again for her powers
and she makes her a deal she says that
if she gives her her powers she'll fix
her spell so that
vision and her kids can live and never
go away
and all of the people of west view won't
have to be in pain anymore
they soon then bust out of the
consciousness that agatha and wanda are
in and begin to fight in real life where
wanda says
take it i don't want it anymore and she
starts to throw her powers at agatha
however
she ends up missing sometimes and this
actually confuses agatha as to how she's
missing
however what we come to find out is this
is actually a plan by wanda and she is
actually casting runes this is exactly
what agatha taught her in the previous
episode
episode 8. and what she learned about
runes is that in a given space
only the witch who cast them can use her
magic and since wanda casts the runes
inside of the space of the hexagon only
wanda can use her magic
and it's a great thing that she casts
them because as soon as agatha takes all
of her powers she immediately turns on
her deal
exclaiming that once the spell is cast
it can't be changed and it's always
going to be broken then she goes to
actually kill wanda but she can't use
her magic
then what's very interesting is that
wanda says but i don't need you to tell
me who i
am and the scarlet witch crown forms on
her once
again this is even after wanda gave all
of the chaos magic
to agatha this means that wanda is truly
destined to be
the scarlet witch it is her title it is
her
crown and if you tie it back to the
comic's origin it's because she was
actually marked
personally by c'thun that's how she got
her powers
so wanda is the scarlet witch it's not
something somebody can take from her or
she can give away
and wanda knows this she knows who she
is and she wears that crown now
then she takes all of that power back
and then we see for the first
time on screen the true scarlet witch in
all of her power and glory wearing her
crown now she unlocked
more chaos magic in herself to become
the scarlet witch not just the ones that
she was using on agatha and this is what
causes agatha to say
oh gosh you don't know what you've done
what she means is you've unleashed the
magic of c'thun the evil elder god
and that's why agatha says when wanda
takes them back down to the ground
you have no idea what you've unleashed
and she tells wanda that she's going to
need her help because eventually
this evil being is going to come but of
course wanda says if she needs her help
she knows where to find her because
wanda
is planning on trapping her in westview
although it's not going to be trapped in
a hexagon
agatha is going to be trapped in a state
of mind basically a prison of the mind
agatha being stuck in the role of the
nosy neighbor
not being free but trapped she returns
to agnes who we knew from the very
beginning and she says i'll be seeing
you agnes
then wanda is reunited with her boys and
vision and then vision says
i know you'll make everything right but
not for us meaning not for the family
because the hex is going to have to go
away which means vision and the twin
boys are going to have to go away
and then wanda says no not for us
implying that
yes vision and the twin boys are going
to have to die
as they start to head to their home
wanda releases the hex
and westview and everybody and
everything inside of it turns back
to normal back at their house wanda and
vision tuck in the twin boys and say
that they're very proud of them
and wanda drops some very interesting
lines she says that family is forever
we could never truly leave each other
even if we tried
this of course ties into the post credit
scene where wanda actually hears the
twin boys
alive somewhere but we have a very
emotional scene where wand and vision
say goodbye to their twin boys
and then it's time for wanda and vision
to say goodbye as the hex is almost gone
vision has to ask a question which is
what am i
he's obviously not the original vision
because he's not made out of vibranium
it's not the same body it's someone that
wanda created
and this is a question that we've all
wanted to know as well that wanda
finally answers
this vision is something that wanda
created that has multiple parts to him
one is a piece of the mind stone that
lives inside of wanda
obviously when wanda came in contact
with the infinity stone
a part of its energy went inside of her
and she inherently has
a part of that mind stone inside of her
she physically created him
out of a body of wires and bones and
blood not vibranium like the original
vision he's also a projection of her
sadness
and hope but most importantly he is her
love
he then says i have been a voice with no
body referring to when he was the ai
jarvis for tony stark he then says i've
been a body but not human
referring to when ultron built the body
a synthesis body not an actual human
and now he was a memory made real by
wanda
he then says who knows what will be next
and they've said goodbye before
so it stands to reason that they'll say
hello again implying that we are indeed
going to see vision or at least a
version of him
in the future this will most likely be
the white vision who took off all of a
sudden
but did have the sudden realization that
he is vision he is the
original vibranium vision who now has
all of the memories
vision says so long darling the hex
completely disappears along with vision
and her kids and west view goes back to
the same dump that it was before
and wanda ends up on the empty lot that
vision bought for her to where they were
going to build their house
wanda now accepts the true reality in
which vision is gone she puts her hood
on and she walks away through the town
where all of the townspeople of west
view know who she is
and knows what she did she's the one who
trapped them
under this spell and caused them a great
amount of pain
and fear and before she leaves she sees
monica rambo in which wanda says she's
sorry and monica says she understands
because if she could bring her mother
back if she had the power to
she would and wanda says she doesn't
understand the power that she has
but she will and of course we know this
because she has the dark hold
she's going to learn all about how to be
a true
witch the scarlet witch she changes into
her true scarlet witch outfit
leaves westview and that is the end of
wanda
vision but keep in mind that kevin feige
the president of marvel studios said
that one division
will have one season but doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is
basically one division season
two but that is it for this season of
wanda
vision i truly enjoyed it i was wrong
about a lot of things
right about some things but i loved
every second of it i loved coming up
with theories i loved all of the watch
parties and talking with you all and in
a couple of weeks we can all be very
excited because the falcon
and the winter soldier starts i'll be
doing watch parties for those as well so
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you can get updates
on the falcon and the winter soldier
and of course let me know what you
thought about the one division finale
in the comments down below don't forget
to give the video a like and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you